bonjour à vous peuple d internet nous
sommes aujourd'hui le 5 décembre
il est 6 heures du matin et c'est
reparti pour une vidéo en plus au départ
je voulais me que ces deux vidéos vous
savez pour cinquième jour du calendrier
de l'avent où j'allais vous parlez de
mémoire est également d'un jeu parce que
c'est un peu le principe de vous donner
des idées de cadeaux de noël
parmi les trucs que moi j'aime utiliser
ce soit des livres des jeux des produits
vaisselle ou ménagés on n'a pas fait ça
viendra t'il 24 décembre
et là je me suis aperçu que sur l'un des
jeux dont je voulais vous parler
aujourd'hui il y avait beaucoup de
choses à dire et beaucoup tout un truc
fun par définition un peu de vous parler
de deux jeux non pas d'un banal non pas
des deux armées de 2 en fait si le jeu
s'appelle kicekafessa qui a fait ça qui
a fait ça c'est que c'est ça qui a fait
ça de topito ses doutes et chez first
c'est évidemment le même éditeur que moi
ya pas de problème mais ça n'empêche que
c'est un placement produit puisque c'est
un jeu que j'ai à kerry par moi-même et
auquel j'ai commencé à jouer
non je le dis parce que si on ne dit pas
après déjà une fois c'est un placement
produit alors que quand c'est un
placement de produit on le dit pas on
dit pas que c'est pas un placement donc
dans ce jeu il ya quasiment pas de
règles c'est d'en prendre une carte et
on pose au jour de gauche et on tourne
comme ça et si la personne a réussi
pendant la question elle marque le point
et c'est que c'est et ce n'est que des
qui a dit ça ou qui a fait ça ou
quelques cartes bonus qui apporte un
petit peu de peps au jeu ça c'est pas
gentil pioche cette carte bonus carte
non mais c'est pas vrai c'est
dégueulasse donc il se passe quoi je
perds tous mes points parce que la vie
est une [ __ ]
oui c'est vraiment marqué ça comme ça
donc vous voyez un petit peu le ton du
jeu et les qui a fait ça et qui a dit ça
sont que des choses réelles qui sont
vraiment passé je vous propose dans
cette vidéo de vous en dire quelques
mots qui a fait ça s'appelait comme une
couleur
j'aime bien clair un d'obscurs chanteur
michel blanc qui a des valeurs
edouard bard je suis enrhumé benjamin
biolay est décidément ce rhume ne
s'arrange pas facile c'est la réponse de
michel blanc du coup je vais essayer
d'en trouver un autre vous voyez un
petit peu l'idée qui a fait ça découper
son père pour en faire un meuble télé
donc ça s'est vraiment passé
quatre propositions néanmoins un un
jeune homme après une légère disputent
deux une jeune femme complètement dans
l'ivresse 3 une prof d'arts plastiques
qui n'avait plus de papier pour son
atelier de découpage 4 luke skywalker
je vous laisse réfléchir et faire votre
proposition dans l'espace commentaire
prévu à cet effet ou peut-être inventé
une cinquième proposition je pense que
ça fait partie du jeu pourquoi pas et la
réponse était la réponse une un jeune
homme après une légère dispute avec son
père il a donc découpé et il y en a fait
un meuble télé histoire vraie parce que
quand c'est une histoire vraie il ya
toujours le petit logo histoire vraie
qui a fait ça je n'étais pas dans des
institutions se masturber à chaque
passage du tracteur un karine lemarchand
acquis l'amour est dans le pré tape un
taux sur le système 2 josé bové on
aurait dû se méfier la moustache depuis
le début 3 and adolescent de
bourg-en-bresse qu'il y assez mal sa
poussée d'hormones ou 4 un gentil
monsieur dans une vidéo star de jackie
et michel
alors d'après vous karine le marchand
josé bové
un adolescent de bourg en bresse ou un
gentil môssieur sur jackie et michel est
la bonne réponse et la réponse je vais
vous entendez le commentaire la réponse
3 un jeune de bourg en bresse qui vivait
très mal sa poussée d'hormones
est ce que j'aurai j'en fais de retour
aller j'en fais encore quelques-unes
alger pas trop fait de ti a dit ça par
contre
qui a dit ça en il est trop facile
celui-là mais comme les propositions son
rôle j'ai quand même voulu venir
qui a dit ça un grand pouvoir implique
de grandes responsabilités
réponse une double dehors qui aime bien
faire chier le monde avec ses grands
principes à la con réponse 2 laurent
voulzy dans le pouvoir des fleurs
réponse 3 serge rouvière après sa
victoire au championnat de pétanque de
1977 et doom
4 un certain benjamin parker à son neveu
axa boutonneux récemment piquée par une
vilaine a régné
la réponse est bien sûr ben parker à son
neveu peter parker alias spider man je
me rends compte au fur et à mesure que
je vous en lits et cette vidéo va être
démonétisé à 6h01 du matin ce que je lis
littéralement c'était de marquer
qui a dit ça bien celui-là la politique
c'est comme de leurs douilles est ça
doit sentir un peu la merde mais pas
trop j'ai le souvenir d'une aiguille est
que j'avais mangé à angers avec votre
cas est unique c'est notre jour et bien
c'est vrai ça sent un peu la réponse une
andré santini entre deux dj stiff
edouard herriot entre deux digestif
aussi mon oncle qui comparent vraiment
tout à de la bouche ou mon boucher entre
deux blagues de cul la réponse est on
sera peut être mon boucher mais non
c'est edouard herriot après de digestif
aussi et on terminera sur le jeu dans la
vidéo reste là jusqu'au bout avec un qui
a fait ça un peu énorme qui a fait ça ça
me fait penser un peu aux jeux qu'on
fait des fois un live index grec qui a
fait ça se suicider pour l'honneur
j'ai bien dû se suicider pour l'honneur
réponse d'une gérante car dans
l'histoire de mourir le jour qu'il avait
annoncé 15 ans avant réponse de maurice
ravel histoire de mourir en écoutant son
boléro réponse 3 rené descartes
l'histoire de mourir avant de terminer
un bouquin trop nulle réponse 4 harry
houdini
histoire de ne pas avoir à faire un tour
de magie qu'à des foires et la réponse
est la réponse une gérante cardan
avaient annoncé qu'ils mourraient tel
jour telle date
quinze ans auparavant et par ego par
orgueil
ce jour là comme il n'était pas malade
etc contrairement à tout ce qu'il avait
prévu
il s'est suicidé pour qu'on puisse pas
lui bien le lendemain à tu vois tu t'es
trompé ça c'est ce qui s'appelle ne pas
assumer avoir tort mais quand même
phrase les cojones pour faire ça voilà
c'est l'idée du jeu vous avez vu c'est
très simple c'est ça se joue mais ça se
lit aussi c'est assez rigolo à lire du
coup on peut aussi en faire une vidéo
dessus
qui sera rempli de mots un petit peu olé
olé dirons nous
ce jeu il me fait clairement penser un
autre jeu dont je n'ai jamais parlé sur
la chaîne parce que il y avait déjà pas
mal de youtube heurts qui avaient fait
des vidéos dessus des deux dernières
années
si vous êtes assez à côté c'est blanc
manger coco c'est un jeu qui n'a pas de
sens c'est super drôle leur commande
c'est vraiment pour adultes et adultes
responsables
qu'est ce que ça va créer des phrase
humoristique parfois qui sont hyper
trash hyper violente
l'idée c'est que d'un côté il ya des
cartes avec des trous il faut compléter
les joueurs ont toujours onze cartes
dans les mains avec des mots permettant
de compléter ces trous et à chaque carte
retournée chacun fait sa proposition
pour compléter et un juge complètement
partiale avec un avis complètement
subjectif va dire lequel des deux est le
plus drôle mais ça peut donner par
exemple ici j'ai un vide avec ça nous a
fait un bien fou encore mieux que la
thalasso et bien ça pourrait donner
l'eau et ses enfants ça nous a fait un
bien fou n'est encore qu'un thalasso ou
ça pourrait donner 18 heures d'histoire
du pastis ça nous fait un bien fou
mieux encore que la thalasso vous avez
compris le principe s'appelle
blanc-manger coco ces deux étudiants
qu'elle a fait ça ça fait un carton
c'est très drôle
il n'y a rien à perdre il n'y a rien à
gagner dans ce jeu à part vraiment se
marrer en fin de soirée ou en début de
soirée ou en milieu de soirée
voilà alors comme d'habitude vous avez
les liens vers ce jeu dans la
description de la vidéo et n'oubliez pas
de laisser un pouce en l'air à la vidéo
aussi à vous appeler de vous abonner si
c'est pas encore fait vous avez
également toutes les informations pour
les questions que vous pouvez vous poser
dans la description j'ai à présent
d'être julien de personnel pas toutes
présentes et questions pour un champion
à demain matin si cela ouais ouais ouais
ouais ouais
[Musique]